لطالما كان الكافيار في عائلتنا ، ما
دمت أتذكر
أنه في الواقع قبل وقتي ،
أتذكر عندما كنت طفلاً على مائدة الإفطار ،
كان لدينا حرفياً ستة علب مختلفة من
الكافيار ، اسمي نيكولاس نارسفيدسا ، أنا
مؤسس مشارك وشريك في  Amster Caviar
أسست عائلتي شركة للكافيار
في جورجيا منذ أكثر من 35 عامًا
، ونحن في الواقع الآن موزع
ومورد لكافيار سمك الحفش في
الولايات المتحدة وفي الشرق الأوسط
عانت عائلتنا من
الإبادة الجماعية الجورجية في أبوسيا في صحومي وكنا كذلك
من بين المحظوظين جدًا الذين
هربوا من جميع الأماكن التي هربنا إليها كانت
الولايات المتحدة في الواقع ، وخلال
ذلك الوقت تقريبًا في عام 1995 عندما وصلنا إلى
هناك ، أصبح الصيد الجائر والصيد الجائر
لسمك الحفش هائلين لدرجة أنه
في عام 98 على مستوى العالم كان هناك استفتاء
للتأكد من حماية جميع أنواع الكافيار وجميع
أنواع سمك الحفش بحيث
يجب تربية جميع أنواع الكيفين وهنا
كنا على بعد حوالي
10 أميال من واحدة من أكبر
مزارع سمك الحفش  في الولايات
المتحدة وجلبنا نوعًا من
وصفات وتقنيات عائلة البحر الأسود الخاصة بنا للشيخوخة ،
لذلك أنشأنا شركة تسمى
amster والتي كانت في الأصل اختصارًا لسمك
الحفش الأمريكي
لتكريم الدولة
التي استقبلت بعض اللاجئين من
مكان صغير  يُطلق عليه اسم georgia
[موسيقى
] أفضل مذاق للكافيار يأتي من
سمك الحفش الذي يربى في موطنه الأصلي
على الساحل الغربي لأمريكا الشمالية ،
هناك بالفعل واحدًا
سائدًا يُسمى asi Pencil transmontinus
المعروف أيضًا باسم سمك الحفش
الأبيض وعندما علمنا في الأصل عن
هذه الأنواع ونحن  تذوقنا الكافيار
تمامًا
وفكرنا في سبب عدم معرفة المزيد من الأشخاص
عنهم ، لذلك فكرنا في نقل هذه القصة إلى
الخارج ودعونا نظهر للناس على مستوى العالم
أن
أفضل تذوق هو أصلي نشأ
[موسيقى]
وصلنا إليه في دبي التقينا ببعض
أشخاص مؤثرون بشكل لا يصدق وكان ذلك في
الواقع أول تسليم لنا في البلاد
ومنذ تلك اللحظة قررنا أن
نبقى على ما هو عليه
سجلان
قياسيان في عالم غينيس ، كان أول رقم قياسي عالمي
لغينيس مع فيرجيل أراب وأنتجنا أكبر
علبة كافيار في العالم
كان وزنها 17.89 كيلوغرامًا ،
وفي اليوم التالي تلقيت مكالمة من أصدقائنا الجيدين
في أتلانتس وقالوا
أحسنت صنعًا ولكن دعنا  دعنا نضاعف
هذا الرقم
[موسيقى]
لذا جلسنا معهم في العام التالي ،
آه 50 كيلوغرامًا
10 بقطر حوالي 75 سنتيمترًا ،
كان الشيء الضخم هو الرقم القياسي الثاني لكافيار غينيس
[موسيقى]
حقًا هو قصة طويلة جدًا
كما هو الحال في
إنه أمر شهي اليوم
لأنه إذا فكرت في الأمر ، فإن الأمر يتطلب
متوسط سمك الحفش ما
ين 8 إلى 12 عامًا أو أكثر من 16 إل
20 عامًا لتنضج لمجرد تحقيق ذل
مع هذا الوقت من الوقت ، لا يمكنك حق
ا وضع قيمة بسيطة عليها  عليك
أن تنظر إلى عنصر الوقت
[الموسيقى]
الذي نود التركيز على كون النكهة هي
الهدف النهائي
وعندما تنظر إلى كل هذه
العناصر المختلفة ، فإن المهم حقًا
أن يفهمه الناس هو
الموطن الأصلي الأول  لقد تطورت الأسماك على مدى
200 مليون سنة ، وهذا ليس
بخسًا ، فهذه حيوانات ما قبل التاريخ
بعد أن كانت وجباتها الغذائية
والمياه لا يعرفها الكثير من الناس ، لكن
طعم الكافيار لا مثيل له ولا
نكهة بمجرد إزالته
من بطن  يتم إنشاء
نكهة السمك بالفعل
بعد عملية الشيخوخة التي
تبرز النكهة ، حيث يمتص الملح
الرطوبة ويطرد بشكل أساسي
كل الدهون وهو ما يخلق هذه
النكهة الرائعة ،
يجب ألا يتذوق الكافيار ذو الجودة العالية مثل
السمك ، يجب أن يتذوق مثل الزبدة
التي تعرفها تلميحات  من البندق أو الجوز
إذا كان في عام 1990
جرة زجاجية سعة 2 لتر ، دعنا نقول أن
كيلوغرامين من
الكافيار يكلفان
حوالي عشرة دولارات
، معايير اليوم هي درجتنا الملكية
التي تعد واحدة من أكثر الأشياء المفضلة أه
أنها تكلف حوالي ثمانية آلاف
دولار لنفس المبلغ
من  في اللحظة التي يتم فيها تفريخ السمكة ،
فعندما تفقس تمامًا
حتى يتم توصيل علبة من الكافيار إلى
مائدتك ، قد يستغرق الأمر  ما يزيد عن 12 عامًا و
16 عامًا أو 25 عامًا ، لذلك عادةً
ما ينتج سمك الحفش
في المتوسط ما بين ثمانية إلى 12 عامًا فو
18 من وزن جسمها يعتمد عل
نوع البطارخ حت
سن الثالثة ، فأ
ت لا تعرف جنس السمكة ، لذ
ك  سيتعين عليك الانتظار حتى
يبلغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات وثلاث سنوات ونصف ،
ثم ستستخدم الموجات فوق الصوتية
لتحديد الجنس في تلك المرحلة ،
وعادة ما يتم
فصل الذكور والإناث عن الإناث في تلك المرحلة
حتى سن الثامنة.  تبدأ
في النضج بما يكفي لإنتاج البطارخ
، ومن تلك النقطة فصاعدًا ، يتم الآن
مراقبتها تمامًا ، ربما
نتذوق الكافيار
أربع أو خمس مرات قبل أن نضع
الدرجة النهائية ونسلمها إلى العميل
لأن الذوق بالنسبة لنا
هو رقم واحد وإذا كان العميل كذلك
عند شراء درجة معينة منا ، فإنهم
يتوقعون ملف تعريف نكهة معينًا وهذا
ما يجب عليهم الحصول عليه وهذا ما
نضمن تقديمه